justin is with us justin's in orlando hi
justin welcome to the dave ramsey show
hi dave thank you for having me sure
what's up
um just want to call in with a quick
question get your your advice and your
input
i'll explain my scenario real quick i am
an elementary school physical education
teacher
i've been teaching now for 11 years and
it's been a wonderful
um career path for my family and it
enabled me to have a wonderful schedule
with my children
and my wife i might have three young
boys under the age of eight
um long story short my wife and i found
her program right before we got married
and um had followed it um as the best we
could all throughout the
years we've been married now for about
nine years um
started off you know working the baby
steps working the debt snowball and and
now
we're in a position where i feel like we
are very very blessed um god has
definitely provided
and your program has has been amazing
um my situation i'm in now is when we
were working the baby steps i kind of
took your your joke of selling the
the dog on craigslist and the cat on on
ebay to heart
and started selling everything on ebay
until we
sold out of all of our own possessions
then i you know took it a little bit
further and started getting into
wholesaling and
little known to me um kind of stumble
upon a business
i've been doing it now for eight
actually sorry about
nine nine and a half years and this last
year um has been my most lucrative in
terms of business in terms of the
business
um it's grown each year and it's it's
honest honestly my passion my dream
um it's enabled my wife to to quit her
job her career job of
working in sports technology and she's
now a stay-at-home mom
and i worked hard to be able to get that
done for her and now i'm kind of at the
point where
i'm itching to to pursue my my passion
in terms of being a full-time e-commerce
seller as well
wow i just want to get your thoughts on
if it made sense in
um if i was making a wise sound decision
and doing so wow
justin don't leave us hanging how much
did you make
this past year um my gross income was
120 000
and i netted about 70. okay and what do
you make at your day job
my day job as a teacher i make 44 000
before taxes
okay and is your livestock what's your
lifestyle set up on you're out of debt
you have an emergency fund right
we're out of debt um i have an emergency
fund fully funded of about fifty
thousand dollars um our mortgage and
house is completely paid off i live in a
three hundred thousand dollar three
hundred and ten thousand dollar house
and it's paid for it's completely paid
for yes sir
you are a rock star brother the ball so
you can live on 70 000 right
i i definitely think so absolutely um
i'm very conservative and i think not
that it scares me i know
um i have enough confidence in myself
but it's you know
going scary committing a lot of my life
to um
to becoming a teacher and going in a
completely different direction
but you obviously have been doing this a
while this is not a lark this isn't
something for one year you did and you
got all pumped up
uh this is something you've gradually
grown over nine and a half years
and it's a legitimate serious business
now
right yes sir okay uh and it's what you
want to do you enjoy it
absolutely i love it okay so when are
you turning in your resignation
well um i'm spoken with my wife and
and i agree with her she she feels that
um i should
you know finish the year teaching okay
and that's the same question go into a
headstrong you know beginning of next
school year after i would quit over the
summer
you know going into the next school year
yeah
that was kind of you know her suggestion
i and i value it you know i'm i'm well
respected in my job and want to leave on
a good term
absolutely and you know finishing out
the school year is kind of a classy
thing to do
no harm no foul you can do that and it
you'll have a lot of energy just knowing
that it's coming to an end that's right
sure even though it feels like it's a
long way away but it's only five months
and so right you know um i would go
ahead and let them know that the
when the school year wraps up you are
and i would get on with my business
uh and i think this i think you will
always be
a teacher it just may not be at that
location in the elementary school you
might teach
someone how to do ebay stuff you might
teach
uh sunday school at your church i don't
know what it is but i think you're a
teacher too
yeah by the way i love teaching yeah by
the way i'm a teacher
it's what i do and i love teaching it's
one of my gifts
as a matter of fact i'm a gifted teacher
a lot of things i'm not gifted at but
that one i am and so
that's uh that's who you are and it does
not have to manifest itself
as a uh elementary pe teacher no and
justin i'm going to tell you buddy
congratulations very very
very very well done uh remember the
principles that got you here
is what i want to leave you with uh
meaning the mindset of looking at and
seeing debt for what it is
it's not a tool it's a threat and so
even as you look to grow in your
business
again please don't let your guard down
please don't think that you suddenly
have to hit a grand slam
when you've been hitting base singles
and you've been winning
yeah so remember those things and don't
deviate from your plan young man
you're on the ball four yards and a
cloud of dust get you get you a uh
a first down every three yeah and you
don't have to worry about it just you
don't have to you don't put the ball at
risk
and that's all that's all we're trying
to do here just it's ball protection
just just finish
out you're doing very very well and jump
onto the entree leadership stuff if you
haven't
and get plugged into the um in the
entree leadership elite and get plugged
into some groups of some of the other
sellers we've got on there they're doing
really well
you can learn a lot from each other as
you go